Red Dead Redemption - is finally
happening and Xbox one owners are going
to have to be just a little more patient
than anyone on ps4 I'm Tony and this is
your Wild West game spot news update ps4
players will get early access to some of
Red Dead Redemption twos online content
as part of Sony's partnership with
Rockstar Games Sony executive John
Kahler went so far as to say that Red
Dead is quote handcrafted to take full
advantage of the ps4 although no solid
details about the early access were
given we'll just have to keep an ear to
the ground for when Sony reveals what
this extra content actually is this
announcement comes on the heels of the
first official Red Dead Redemption 2
trailer which frankly didn't tell us too
many details either but we did get a
connection to the first game as the
narrator does sound like John Marsten's
old gang leader dutch van der Linde
Red Dead Redemption 2 was coming to Xbox
one and ps4 in fall 2017 so stick with
GameSpot for tons of coverage as we get
closer to launch and for all the latest
on rockstars upcoming games you're
already in the right place